hey what's up guys welcome back to our
channel my name's samuel and i'm amanda
and this is the samuel and amanda show
where we talk about money marriage and
life that's correct and right now we are
going to be doing a um a podcast video
called the truth about millionaires
because there is a quiz that i found
online which is called the truth about
millionaires i don't know if you can see
that and it asks a whole bunch of
questions about millionaires you have to
say true or false and i figured we'd do
it on the podcast and uh and see if we
have the same answers and also see what
you guys think as well
so we're gonna be answering these
questions in a moment but before we do
that how's your week been what have you
been up to my week's been pretty cool um
nice changing up the house a little bit
so just been doing a little bit of
decoration and things like that
and um yeah spending time with the kids
as usual that's great i've been um
trying to get planning permission on
some different sites viewing a lot of
properties having a lot of visitors over
as well and um i'm right now in the
middle of the tour the the um rent to
rent revolution tour so i'm going to be
back on tour tomorrow so it's been a
really really really crazy week if
you've got questions for us comment them
below we are going to be saving your
questions till the end of the video so
comment your questions below in the
video and we'll be answering your
questions at the end of the video fair
enough yeah okay so
the truth about millionaires think you
know what millionaires are really like
take this short quiz and see if you are
right so there's ten questions are you
ready yes i'm ready i'm jordan ready all
right here we go so number one is if you
say whether you think it's true or false
okay and then i'll give my opinion and
then we'll see what the actual results
are i have not cheated i have not seen
what the results are this is the first
time doing this quiz okay okay so number
one
most millionaires
inherited
their money true or false
oh
i don't know i'd say obviously you don't
know yeah i know i know
what do i think i think false okay
because don't know isn't on this i know
i was just thinking i'm gonna say
thinking out loud i'm gonna say false as
well because i don't think that oh oh i
just pressed it and it came up and
correct that's correct so
statistics say only 19 of millionaires
were given any money or wealth from
family interesting that is interesting
so 81 of millionaires made it themselves
that's really really interesting all
right next number two millionaires don't
actually work they have people who work
for them i'd say true
i'm gonna say false okay okay talk to me
why you think true okay okay okay um i
can see why you'd say the opposite but i
think yes because i think to be at the
top you kind of have to delegate and
you're going to have a team of people
that are actually doing the work for you
so they're gonna out get yeah outsource
a lot of stuff yeah and get people to i
disagree okay oh i think number one i
think that millionaires
are hard workers so even if they've got
a team under them they're still gonna
work really hard anyway and the question
is millionaires don't actually work
that's ridiculous um and the second
thing is i think that most millionaires
yeah
are employees
okay what to their own company
to the company that they work for okay
i mean some of our guys that work for us
are getting pretty wealthy yeah a
million pounds isn't that much money i
think that most millionaires make their
money by working at the corporate ladder
yeah getting paid well investing their
money
you don't have to be an entrepreneur or
a business owner anyway let's find out
you can say i'm gonna say millionaires
don't actually work
i'm they have people who work for them
i'm gonna say false but you had said
true oh no you cut out right i was right
yeah samuel was right it says
um it says most work more than 45 hours
a week yeah okay i can kind of get that
i can kind of get that i think i was
just thinking
i was probably wrong because yeah i mean
yeah okay they're the brains of the
operations of course you're gonna work a
lot but
millionaires shop in ve oh your last one
shopping millionaires shop in very
exclusive stores not where ordinary
people shop true or false
this is so annoying this quiz because
why is it annoying because i think
people are different and i think there's
some millionaires that love
why it says
okay most of them do so i'll say true
you say they're shopping exclusive
stores yes i'm gonna say that's false
i'm um hold on then there's shopping
votes i'm gonna say false i'm gonna say
that millionaires shop in ordinary
stores
i'm going to say that they like shopping
in exclusive schools
no stop one that one there okay
false
shopping oh i was right again so samuel
was right apparently 43 percent of
millionaires have a sears card and i
think sears
is this is an american store
very basic
basic i don't know but it's very normal
okay interesting so so far i've been
writing everyone and you've been wow i
know interesting so all right next
millionaires
drive impressive cars true or false i'll
say false now
now i'm thinking of the book the
millionaire next door just okay i feel
like this is just based off of that
clearly no
i just found it online
i'm gonna say that that's false as well
yeah although i like us not having the
same opinion because then it means i'm
usually right samuel just wants the
drama
originally because millionaires drive
impressive cars i don't think they do i
think that people that drive really
impressive cars generally speaking yeah
probably aren't millionaires they're
really stretching but when you're
actually a millionaire like
i don't think you have to impress
anybody no just you're trying to
appreciate whatever so okay you press
and see what it is so we're gonna say
we're both gonna say false yes we're
both gonna say false to that one oh
we're right only 23 percent of
millionaires drive a new car
wow that's interesting all right next
most millionaires make their money in
glamorous ways they are basketball
players musicians or other celebrities
i'll say true that's totally false go on
i want to be opposite false no but you
have to actually think okay go on most
millionaires work in very ordinary jobs
that's what i said at the beginning
what's
samuel likes being right if you can't
tell well
this is a game right everyone wants to
win they are paving
oh wow look at that most millionaires
working very ordinary jobs they are
paving contractors or have a pest
control business wow pest control so
it's pest control the business to be in
if you're not in property
[Music]
a business opportunity
or an umbrella or an umbrella business
what do you mean an umbrella business
vending machine oh yes
i've got this i've got this idea i
always say to samuel i really want to
have a vending machine in a train
station in all train stations that sells
umbrellas because there's nothing worse
than when you're out and it's raining
and then there's no umbrellas and i just
think that they just sell all the time
really really well so yeah maybe okay
millionaires have lots of credit cards
i'll say true i'll say false i mean
we have one credit card
yeah but okay i'm looking at it as more
like millionaires like to leverage other
people's money yes they do so i just
think that i'm gonna say false i'm gonna
say they have one not lots but go on
click it
false i was right
oh my goodness i have a feeling samuel
looked at this i did not looked up all
the answers
just to try and make me look a bit silly
here no
it says many keep just one credit card
i love that i'm not just right
i love how right now i can't deal i
think next time i'm gonna pick a quiz
that i i don't know i happen to know the
answers to but go on okay many take just
one credit card and most pay off in full
each month they do not like paying
interest on debt
okay number seven there's ten if you
enjoy the video hit the like button
if you're loving the fact that i am
winning
um okay no next number seven
number seven most millionaires own their
own business i'm gonna say false
come on we're gonna say i'm gonna say
true okay go on
you might be brought on this one
oh yeah
you're wrong
oh man oh that's annoying okay it says
here most millionaires consider
themselves to be entrepreneurs this may
explain why they work more hours than
you would think they are decision makers
for their own companies i'm i'm ruined
now that sucks i thought i was going to
get every single winning streak there
yeah that sucks okay next
number eight many poor people become
millionaires by winning the lottery
oh
i'd say false i'd say false come on
false false very interesting statistic
statistics say that the chances of
winning the powerball lottery are won
in
17
billion wow that's crazy you have a
better chance of being struck by
lightning your chances of that are one
in nine million wow therefore you if you
want you have better chances of being
struck by lightning that's crazy like
like again and again
yeah yeah so okay number nine most
millionaires are college graduates i'm
gonna say false i'm gonna say false
true wow what interesting what i'm
surprised actually nine out of four out
of five millionaires are college
graduates wow that's interesting yeah i
never graduated college 24 have earned a
master's hmm
another 14 have earned medical or law
degrees they are well educated wow
that's interesting mm-hmm okay i guess
you can't argue with stats
[Music]
all right lastly number 10
there is a good possibility that you can
be a millionaire what do you reckon or
false true why do you reckon true
because i think that it's it's down to
hard work isn't it
no but the person reading this quiz
why would there be a good chance i mean
if you're if you're hearing this from us
there's a good chance you will be
because you're watching the channel but
i'm trying to work out why wouldn't say
there is a good possibility
statistically there's not a good
possibility statistically you're not
going to be a millionaire because most
people aren't so why
i'm not taking an interest and i don't
know you down this gone on this on this
quiz then maybe you're interested
somehow i don't
[Music]
it is not true that hard it is not that
hard if you stick to a saving plan
let's say you invest three thousand
pound each year from 21 to 64 when you
want to retire and earn eight percent
you will retire with a million bucks you
know what though that's actually that's
actually incorrect because there is a
good possibility that you
i guess you he says you can be not you
will be so it's true yeah
anyway what do you think guys
interesting do you agree with do you
agree or disagree with any of the
answers let us know in the comments
okay some questions that we had uh okay
so we had a question last week bother if
you've got questions why should they
comment their questions below should
comment them so then we can answer them
and then you get to know what we think
of whatever you're asking we had a
question last week from n
uh how do you pass that arena
did you ever work and earn as children
and if so how was the experience
i didn't so my parents were really
strict and really wanted me to do really
well in school so i never actually had a
job until i was 18 years old and it was
just because they wanted me to be so
focused on on they wanted you to do well
in your college graduation because they
know that most millionaires get a good
quality right
i had lots of jobs i used to wash cars i
used to cut people's lawns i used to
sell magic tricks even while i was at
school at 15 years old i set up a
plastering company um i had a lot of
businesses and jobs as a kid
yeah so that's where it'll be different
and yeah
maybe that's why i did slightly better
at the quiz
maybe who knows okay um who is your best
friend
wow is that really a question really a
question ah samuel's my best friend all
i'm gonna have to say i wanna know thank
you i'm gonna say russell's my best
friend wow he's just saying that to
wyoming russell i'm samuel's best friend
just so you know yeah
who is your
who is your favorite child
wow
is that even i can't answer that i love
them all the same i really really did
that i haven't got a favorite that one
wasn't really a question
what if i said like one of their names
what would you have said i would have
quickly gone and told them
[Applause]
okay guys i hope you enjoyed this video
don't forget to smash like also
subscribe ask your questions below in
the comment box and we will see you next
week
see you guys
[Music]